2021 was a big year for resignations
across the board everybody's heard of
the great resignation where people left
their jobs because of burnout or because
they were leaving for greener pastures
but some people left their jobs in more
notable flame outs here are picks for
the 2021 biggest career crashes
one of the biggest career crashes of the
year was the now former governor of new
york andrew cuomo
he was as the pandemic started the
perfect pandemic era leader he earned
all kinds of applause for his sort of
somber voice of reason as he was
compared to
other officials in washington who seem
to be downplaying the risks of the
coronavirus since then he's been charged
with forcible touching a misdemeanor
crime that he's denied he's also denied
making inappropriate sexual advances and
in his latest fall from grace cuomo has
been ordered to turn over millions of
dollars in profits from his pandemic
memoir by the new york state ethics
board
early in the pandemic many people will
remember cnn host chris cuomo and his
brother andrew cuomo and their familiar
sibling banter on cnn as they discussed
coronavirus but that closeness really
came under scrutiny
after the governor's sexual harassment
investigation occurred
as that happened it was discovered that
chris cuomo the cnn host had
counseled his brother
in terms of public statements that were
made
crossing a journalistic line
cnn decided to fire chris cuomo in
december following his allegations his
termination also followed allegations
that he too had been accused of sexual
misconduct an allegation cuomo has
denied
market has changed as you know
and
we have to move
with it
in order to survive for a case study in
what not to do when laying off employees
it's hard to top the now infamous zoom
call in which better.com ceo vishal garg
fired 900 of his people
if you're on this call
you are
part of the unlucky group being laid off
he said the last time i did this i cried
and this time time i hope to be stronger
and ultimately it led to varg who has
apologized for it and has a history of
financial and legal entanglements taking
a leave that was effective immediately
according to an internal memo
hip-hop star travis scott has been
hailed by forbes as a brand whisperer to
corporate america
but even if blame is unclear on what
happened at astro world the music
festival in november where 10 concert
goers died amid a crowd surge many other
people were injured and lawsuits are
pending
some brands have begun distancing
themselves from scott and his empire
anheuser-busch recently said it's
discontinuing scott's cacti hard seltzer
last month nike postponed a shoe
collection
with scott and production company mega
64 said it had terminated an upcoming
project featuring scott
meanwhile with a petition that has more
than 60 thousand signatures
billboard confirmed that scott it will
not be part of the coachella 22 music
festival lineup scots apologized and
offered to pay funeral costs for victims
some of whom have rejected the offer
finally there's matt duran the
australian tv host who lost the right to
air a coveted interview with superstar
adele after he admitted to the singer
during the interview that he had not
heard her album
the reason duran missed a link that was
emailed to him by her record company
that's absolutely the stuff of
nightmares for journalists or anybody
else who's dealing with the fire hose of
a full inbox
still it's a reminder to prepare for key
interviews in an apology duran said the
story sparked a torrent of abuse and
mockery from around the world and he
apologized to adele as well as her
australian fans saying that the email
was by an absurdly long margin the most
important email i've ever missed in my
life
that's for sure
[Music]
you